can you say anything about how the
problem of
evil uh might have constellated itself i
guess we're circling around that a
little bit
in in personal experience in
in the jungian community and as
the years went on i mean doesn't it
constellate itself right in your own
backyard yeah naturally
obviously but jung's awareness of the
problem of evil was not
did not spring from there he took very
much part in what was happening in the
world
and he was very very worried over the
first world war as you can
take out his memories in the second and
he was very terrified of the third one
of a holocaust of our whole culture he
seriously reckoned with that and via
that the problem of evil has come into
being a major preoccupation while the
the constant mischief and jealousies and
the animus
animal announcements that he that he
took more on his stride you know
he didn't take that very practically he
just said ah
are you so infantile and uh i
and all those pupils i have trained here
so long and they are still just
kindergarten he just cursed it but
it didn't upset him but what you would
call the personal shadow of people
didn't upset him he just
grumbled and cursed a bit but that's not
the problem of evil it's that major evil
of
complete destruction which we're reading
and his real approach to that was the
inner
work yes that he did the only thing you
can do the only thing you can do
to confront yourself with it
where you are all the rest all the
benevolent if benevolent preaching would
help
then we would be out of the trouble long
ago because we have
we get a lot of benevolent and
reasonable preaching that it doesn't
help
so the only place where you can really
put the hand on it and deal with it
body to to body the problem of evil is
in yourself
and there you have to the hope to change
something but the hope to change the
world is a
childish illusion
go and tell khamenei that he is
possessed
you can cut your head off
seems almost impossible
that enough people in our time
would be wise enough or courageous
enough to choose the inner way
with the problem of evil it's so
tempting to try to be heroic and act
outwardly yes for example
uh all over the world the nuclear
um weapons and the nuclear power yes
that's developing
it makes me want to jump up and run out
and spend all my time and money
to try to stop the you know that
rather than do the end soon run up
against some
obscure lobbies where all your efforts
get blocked
i i think one should say it aloud
one should not be a coward one should
make demonstrations one
should go against it but one should not
waste
all one's energy into it because it
doesn't help
which would say one's opinion and that's
all then but for the rest fight inwardly
because you see finally it's not we who
will decide that question it is the
collective unconscious which will decide
or
in the religious language god and
if you work on your own problem then
you might get into analysis a politician
who has influence
and then you have done more than if you
had gone in the street with a
transparent every day
and that's that you get a an influential
politician into your analysis or
suddenly interested in union psychology
you can't make
you can only work on yourself and that
is the unconscious and therefore
i see if god wants to save the world
he will put certain call up certain
people to
to know certain things we can't do it
it happens always as a miracle
unexpectedly but you can go
to meet that miracle by working on
yourself